how are you guys doing
what i want to say is this i just was
walking back from the gym
and i thought i'd actually
make this video
and share what's on my mind because i
was thinking about this
first and foremost i've been online for
about seven years i've been in the
public sphere for about seven years now
which is approaching a decade
and in that time i've gone through a
roller coaster of emotions
it's been a very tempestuous and
tumultuous time in terms of my own
spiritual development as well as my own
psychological growth
and
i have to be honest with you
since we're being open and honest that
in the beginning of my journey and even
up until quite recent recently
when people used to criticize me and
it's still the case i'm not saying i'm
being alleviated of this fully but
when people criticize me
um i've had this tendency to have a
knee-jerk impulsive reaction
anger disgust maybe resentment
um
why is that i don't know
and sometimes i'll justify it
to myself in a put in like an ad hoc way
and i'd say to myself something like
look at them they're challenging the
truth
you know
and i would convince myself that the
reason why i was angry with them
was whoever the haters may be
uh especially especially muslim haters
because within my own community it's
like the closer they are to you the
people the the more raw the criticism
can be
that i would convince myself that the
reason why i have this very strong and
raw emotion towards them
is because they're challenging the truth
and look how unjust they are they are
and i have to make the truth clear and
known and all these kind of things
but throughout ramadan and the more i
introspect about this matter the more i
actually realize that
there's only a certain degree of truth
in that proposition
like
probably and i would say this you know
honesty yeah
the reason why i probably felt so
um
outraged
okay disappointed outraged angry
whatever it may be yeah
was simply because
i love myself
very much
myself very much i know that sounds
quite an
embarrassing thing maybe to admit
but like
that's the truth it's self-love yeah
now the truth is i think all of us have
that aspect of
self-love in us and if you want to call
it narcissism call it that
but for me it was particularly um
it was it was particular it was
particularly pronounced i would say yeah
and the more i think about it
the more i thought about i should say
here
the more i realized that actually
all these critics
were doing me the biggest favor of order
honestly
i spoke to one of them actually on the
phone and morgan mentioned here
and he interestingly said about himself
that it's a win-win situation when i get
criticized it's either that
it's either that the person is taking
away from my sins
if i'm in if i'm on deviance then the
person is helping me get away from
deviance and alleviating my sin on the
day of judgment
or that they are oppressing me in which
case i will get their reward on the day
of judgement
and the more i think about it the more i
realize that critics are the greatest
help of all
man
is
motivated almost entirely by his
insecurity
and i'm not different
and so when someone criticizes you
especially if there's a degree of truth
and legitimacy of their criticism
whether it's your work or you as a
person or behavior
it does have an impact
and since we all have this self-love and
let's say
mine was particularly pronounced at
least in my own self-assessment
it was not comfortable
however now
since i've kind of rationalized this to
myself
i'll be honest with you
i have changed the way i look at critics
when
especially muslim critics now they come
out and they speak about me
i have actually changed the way my
emotional
disposition towards them has changed
i'm not making this up i'm not saying
this to school points on the public
sphere
but i'm just sharing this to let you
know that this is possible
that you can actually change your
emotional
you can actually change your emotional
reactive
capacity yeah
towards people from resentment and there
i even go to as far as to say verging on
hate
and anger and disappointment and disgust
almost
to the complete opposite
almost to like now i
wa
like some critic especially muslims
actually only muslims what i'm about to
say now
i actually feel a sense of appreciation
to them
like recently there was one particular
critic of my essay
um
that they were doing this like message
thing where they were doing a whole
session about me and talking about
literally taking my quotes and
talking about me and stuff like that and
saying he made this mistake he made his
mistake here and like it was a 30 minute
or 40 minute session
and i couldn't watch all of it even but
what i'm saying is i'm thinking wow
you're actually investing time into me
like that
yeah i mean
honestly i felt i felt a sense of
gratitude towards them almost
because critics
are sometimes the greatest force of
change so what i'm saying to you is if
someone criticizes you in your life
yeah
don't always show the need
to react to that or to attack them like
i have been doing for the last seven
years i'm not telling you this in a
sanctimonious way i'm telling you this
in a way to actually
all that you know i've been i'm so good
at this
i'm telling you this because it's
honestly this is it's possible
i want you to know that it's possible
and there's one a in the quran that has
really especially when it comes to
muslims has has changed my
has really checked me
which is
not put in my heart any resentment to
those who have believed
so what i'm saying is
there's a way to change the matter
there's a way you can change
your feeling of anger and resentment and
embitterment
to to a more
refreshing kind of gratitude there's a
way of doing that
but it requires i think it does require
some deep introspection
and you need to kind of abstract
yourself from yourself de-individualize
yourself look at yourself from the
outside like as if you were not you yeah
i mean that's what i had to do and then
i when when you started doing that start
realizing okay this person has a point
this person from their world view or
their perspective whatever maybe they're
doing it for this reason
and then you start to actually forgive
people
as the quran states you know do you not
want people to forgive you your ham and
philadelphia memphis
be merciful to those under the hadith
says that be merciful to those on the
earth and allah the one and the the one
in the
heaven will be merciful to you
so what i'm saying is
i want to share that with you because
i'm going on a journey
maybe a lot of people are influenced by
my journey so this is
part and parcel of my journey my journey
is that now that i look at people
criticism critics have for me
i don't feel the same sharp i'm not
saying now someone criticizes me i don't
feel anything still i do feel something
but i've become so desensitized to it
and i can see it for what it is that
actually both the criticism and the
critic for me
are two different things as they were
before
and i hope if and it's so liberating
honestly like
it is spiritually and psychologically
liberating if
i feel like if more if we could do more
of that
as a community
in our families and our communities in
in our dealings with other muslims
if we can do more of that wallahi i
think it's
it will alleviate so much of the
anxieties of life so much of the
stresses of life so much of the problems
in life
and it'll make life better
but of course that doesn't mean to say
these critics
the armchair critics and all these guys
can just do and say whatever they want
because sometimes they do go far
but for the most part now if if the
reaction
is
is more measured from outside
then as i say it's going to be a
positive force for che for good
i hope that makes sense guys i know i've
been rambling but i haven't with these
kind of car talks and stuff i don't plan
them i'm just
this stuff has been swelling around and
fermenting in my mind for some time
so i thought i'll
bring it up sorry come on